all right tonight it is official another
whopping three quarters of a percent
interest rate hike from your fed coming
up we're going to explain in great
detail how this is going to impact your
ability to get a loan pay off debt
finance a car house whatever and how
many americans will now be shut out of
the dream the american dream of owning a
home thanks to joe biden's insane
economic and energy policies now
breaking only moments ago senator joe
manchin just gave in to the radical
climate alarmist cult new green deal
cult agreeing to new massive spending
deal now we're going to show you how his
deal is going to hurt the people
specifically in his state of west
virginia and hurt them dramatically plus
another day another scandal surrounding
the president's son and bagman hunter
biden and later we're going to bring you
disturbing new details about justice
kavanaugh's would-be assassin and by the
way in a terrible decision tonight in
the nicola sandman case we'll tell you
about that but first tonight we begin
you probably didn't notice but joe biden
has been in isolation for about a week
following his covet 19 diagnosis good
news tonight he's apparently all better
and resuming his normal schedule which
is like his covet schedule and that is
waking up late going to bed early plenty
of naps in between very few public
events and during a speech in the rose
garden as you just saw
about covin and his covert journey biden
had to evoke the uniter that he is his
favorite subject donald trump take a
look
here's the bottom line
when my predecessor got covered he had
to get helicoptered to walter reed
medical center he was severely ill
thankfully he recovered
when i got coveted i worked from
upstairs to the white house and the
office is upstairs and uh for the that
five-day period the difference is
vaccinations of course
now what joe failed to mention is the
current variant which is ba 5 the
dominant variant of omicron is much much
weaker than the original strain that
infected then president trump and by the
way not that i recall i never saw donald
trump trip not once not twice but three
times climbing up the stairs to air
force one and then having a spokesperson
claim it was very windy i don't know
what's worse that he tripped three times
or they say the wind blew him over
donald trump never got blown over by the
wind in fact this current covet variant
is so weak that even yeah how frail
cognitively impaired 79 year old can
recover at home with no problem
whatsoever and by the way he forgot to
mention he took the antiviral medicine
pax lavid
so joe's recovery was aided by a highly
effective new treatment and of course
biden was also helped by the vaccines
which were made possible by president
trump's operation warp speed but god
forbid president biden would ever give
any uh credit to his predecessor you
know the uniter in chief that he is just
doesn't seem to have it in him take a
look
millions of americans have used paxil
avoid factual evidence excuse me
pax low vid
i tell you what
i i think it's i used it
no pax lovin including me
pax lavigo not pax lovid pax levitt
anyway joe biden's a train wreck his
presidency and abject failure and
according to the white house press
secretary everything is going great
americans are more prosperous than ever
before we're not in a recession and
based on the administration's brand new
definition of a recession they would be
right except it's not the true
definition of a recession take a look
why is it the white house officials are
trying to redefine
recession no we're not redefining
recession if we all understand a
recession to be two consecutive quarters
of negative gdp growth in a row and then
you have white house officials come up
here to say nothing else that's not what
a recession is it's something else how
is that not redefining recession because
that's not the definition
that is not the definition
said in 2008 of course economists have a
technical definition
which is of a recession which is two
consecutive quarters
of negative growth
i can tell you this they said two
consecutive two negative quarters of gdp
growth is not the technical definition
of recession it is not it is not why did
he say that it
ouch checkmate peter ducey it's no
wonder 75 percent of democratic voters
want someone else at the helm in 2024
even according to a fake news cnn poll
take a look
75 percent the vast majority of
democrats three out of four don't want
biden to be their nominee in 2024. that
is according to a new cnn poll out front
now david axelrod former senior adviser
to president obama
david i i heard that and sort of stopped
in my tracks for a second three quarters
of democrats don't want the incumbent
president to run again
how worried should
biden be right now about that
well i mean obviously this is a this is
a very unhappy uh bit of data for him
and i'm sure
you know
it is concerning
it's it's a little more than concerning
david it's deeply humiliating for joe
biden and it speaks volumes even
democratic leaders in congress including
some of joe's old friends from the
senate they are openly refusing to
endorse a joe biden's second term take a
look at this do you support the
president in his re-election
bid i'm working on my own election and
that's all i'm focused on right now the
president chooses uh to run again in
2024 i mean first of all i'm focused on
winning this majority right now
and preserving a majority this year in
2022 so we'll cross that bridge when we
get to it but
but i think if if the president has a
vision and that's something certainly
we're all willing to entertain and
examine do you believe president biden
should run for a second term
i have said if he runs i'll support him
do you want to see joe biden run for a
second term
yeah i you know that's an easy question
that's not going to take long do you
want to see joel i don't want to answer
that question because we have not that's
not yet i don't want to answer that
question okay um i mean he's the
president and he has the right to to run
for a second term absolutely that is
good i don't want to i don't i don't
want i'd rather you not
wow he has the right to run it isn't
just about biden's age cognitive decline
instead the entire administration has
failed on literally every key issue
problems democrats have is who are they
going to elect that would adopt better
economic and energy policies because i
don't see that happening because 95
percent of the democratic party is part
of the climate alarmist cult from
afghanistan to covet to our southern
border to gas prices inflation the
supply chain you name it widespread
failure and now he's going to waste what
billions more dollars on climate
initiatives and tax evil corporations
how many times have i told you
corporations do not pay taxes when those
new tax hikes joe manchin go into effect
they will pass them on to the people in
west virginia and the other 49 states
great win joe
and tonight there is yet another looming
threat that the white house is all but
ignoring put simply that is the people's
republic of china it is a massive
problem two years after infecting the
world with covert 19 china's communist
dictatorship is now openly threatening
to invade taiwan they're waging a bloody
genocide against the country's minority
uyghur population they're trampling on
human rights in hong kong and they're
threatening our own speaker of the house
nancy pelosi this is a line that's being
crossed when we visit an ally taiwan
sadly china's communist party is also a
malignant force in the united states
intellectual property theft mass
production of fentanyl that they bring
to our southern border widespread
espionage china is constantly looking to
get ahead at our expense it's a hostile
regime and not led by a hostile actor
now even worse is china is now
harvesting your data
spying on your family in plain sight
they do it through the popular
chinese-owned app known as tick-tock
here's joe rogan explaining why
tick-tock is and can be a legitimate
threat to your privacy and your security
take a look at this
i think they saw that people are
addicted to social media and they came
up with the most addictive version of
social media which is tick tock it's the
most addictive by far it's the best for
sucking people in my kids are hook line
sinkered on that and i know a lot of
other people hook line and secure it to
grown people it's good it's good and it
starts playing things immediately the
moment you turn it on it's like playing
your new thing playing you're like
you just sucked into it and all the
while it's monitoring your keystroke
audio settings but by audio settings
that means it has access to your
microphone that means it's listening to
you right now just tell me how it ends
man it ends with china having all of
your data
and if they develop if they get all the
data currency then what well
and to be clear we're not accusing joe
rogan of being a conservative might get
upset now to recap china are they really
harvesting our data spying on our
families stealing our technology
threatening to invade our ally taiwan
killing our people in this country
flooding the country with fentanyl and
now they're buying up thousands upon
thousands hundreds of thousands of acres
of american land that would include 300
acres near a top secret u.s military
drone base in north dakota 130 000 acres
near a u.s air force base in texas all
told china has either purchased land
installed telecommunications equipment
near four u.s air force bases this is
deeply concerning any american land
owned by china's communist government is
a huge problem
here's what one rancher because they're
buying up branches and farmland uh in
droves
literally hundreds of thousands of acres
this is what one rancher told their own
sarah carter take a look
i mean it's kind of stunning the chinese
communist party is actually purchasing
property in
the united states of america here
farmlands ranches
you know you're right it is very
shocking and they're known you know
adversaries of the united states so how
are we allowing that to happen and uh
you know someone needs to ask that hard
question and dive into that and and hold
someone accountable for that because
it's gonna you know it's it's not gonna
turn out in a in a good manner the ranch
is right we need to ask the question
biden needs to answer it because he's
doing nothing however i must give credit
where it's due to the chairman of the
joint chiefs and that would be general
milley he's been meeting with his
counterparts in the region uh hopefully
building strong enough partnerships to
be able to stand up to china especially
their very strong territorial ambitions
towards taiwan and elsewhere and at the
same time the administration is now
looking to ease tariffs increase imports
and make matters worse you know one
million barrels of american oil that
biden released from our strategic
petroleum reserves shipped to china
that's for us in case of an emergency
what's really going on here with the
full report hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else